Merhaba. 30. dersimiz olan bu derste
farklı bir çalışma yapacağız. Bu
dersimizde yeni bir konu anlatmayacağım.
Onun yerine şu ana kadar geldiğimiz
noktada edindiğimiz bilgileri kullanarak
cümleler kurmaya çalışmanızı
isteyeceğim. Buna kaynak olarak da
çeviri ile öğrendeki bir genel revizyon
ünitesini kullanacağız.
Çeviriyile öğreni hazırlarken bir
sayfada bütün cümlelerde aynı gramer
konusu test edildiğinde bir süre sonra
cümlelerin düşünmeden sistematik olarak
çevrilebildiğini fark ettim. Bu bir
olumsuzluktu. Bunun önüne geçmek için
son 5 veya 10 üniteyi kapsayacak şekilde
farklı konulardan cümleler içeren genel
revizyon ünitelerini ekledim.
Genel revizyon ünitelerinde farklı
derslerde edindiğiniz bilgileri ölçen
çeviriler yapmanız istendiği için bu
üniteler alternatif düşünmeye sevk
ediyor.
Ayrıca unutulan konuların hatırlanması
açısından da fayda sağlıyor.
Sizin için kitapta olmayan 20 cümlelik
hayali bir genel revizyon ünitesi
hazırladım. Bu ünite sadece bundan
önceki 29 dersi kapsıyor.
Cümleleri Türkçeden İngilizceye
çevireceğiz. Tüm bu süreçte neyi nasıl
çevireceğimize dair bilgiler vereceğim.
Her yeni cümleden sonra videoyu durdurun
ve cevabınızı bir yere not edin.
Hazırsanız ilk cümlemiz gelsin.
Babanın arabası kaç yaşında?
6. Dersimizin konusu olan bu soru
cümlesine how old ifadesiyle
başlıyorduk.
Peşinden kullanacağımız özneye uygun bir
yardımcı fiil geliyor. Sonra da öznemiz
gelecek. Öznemiz olan babanın arabası
kısmını çevirirken aitlik bildiren ve
sadece insanlarda ve hayvanlarda
kullanılan apostrof s takısını
getireceğiz. Bu da 12. dersin konusuydu.
How old is your father's car?
İspanyalı mısınız?
7. dersimizin konusu olan bu evet
hayırlı soru cümlesine diğer tüm evet
hayırlı sorularda olduğu gibi yardımcı
fiille başlıyoruz. Yardımcı fiili özneye
göre seçelim. Sonra then done dan
anlamını veren from ve ardından da
İspanya gelecek.
Are you from Spain?
Annen doktor mu?
Bakın bu da bir evet hayırlı soru
cümlesi. Buna da yardımcı fiille
başlayıp özne getiriyorum. Daha sonra
meslekleri anlattığım 9. derste de
öğrettiğim gibi mesleğin başına e n
sözcüklerinden birini getiriyorum.
Is your mother a doctor?
O çocuklar okulun önünde.
Bu cümlede o çocuklar diyebilmek için
10. dersi iyi anlamamız gerekiyor.
İşaret sıfatı görevindeki o kelimesini
İngilizcede sadece that ve does
sözcükleri karşılıyordu. Öznemiz çoğul
olduğu için kullanacağız ve olumlu bir
cümle olduğu için özne ile başlayacağız.
Ardından yardımcı fiil gelecek. Önünde
derken de 11. derste öğretilen in front
of ifadesini kullanıyoruz. in front of
yazdıktan sonra peşinden sadece school
yazarsam cümlenin anlamı o çocuklar okul
önünde gibi bir şey oluyor. Özelden
genele indirip bilinen bir okul olduğunu
vurgulamak için başına the getiriyoruz.
The kullanımının ayrıntılarını da 5.
derste bulabilirsiniz.
Those children are in front of the
school.
Evinin numarası ne?
Bu cümlede wh soru kelimelerinden biri
olan what sözcüğü geçtiği için cümlenin
en başına yazılması gerekiyor. Cümle
halen bir soru cümlesi olduğu için
peşinden önce yardımcı fiil ardından
özne geliyor.
Aviin diyebilmek için apostrof s
kullanamıyoruz. Çünkü onu sadece
insanlarda ve hayvanlarda
kullanabildiğimizi 12. derste
söylemiştik. Biz burada yine aynı derste
anlattığım of sözcüğünü aitlik
belirttiği ev kelimesinin başına
koyacağız.
What's the number of your house?
Ben yarışta 3üncüyüm.
Özneyile başlıyorum ve peşimden yardımcı
fiilim geliyor. Sayıları anlattığım 13.
videoyu izlerseniz 1inci, 2inci, 3ünc
gibi ifadeleri öğrenebilirsiniz.
Yarışta sözcüğünün sonundaki dda
kısmıyla kastedilen şey yarışın içinde.
Bu yüzden in kullanacağım. I'm the third
in the race.
Saat 4e 3 var.
Saat söyleme cümlesini kurarken it is
şeklinde başlıyoruz. Ardından önce
dakikayı daha sonra var geçiyor
ifadelerini son olarak da saate
yazıyoruz.
Ancak saatleri anlattığım 14. Videoda da
belirttiğim gibi dakika kısmı 5 ve 5'in
katlarından biri değilse sayının yanına
dakika anlamını gelen minut sözcüğünü
getiriyoruz. It is 3 minutes to.
Bu geniş bir kanepe mi?
Sıfat tamlaması şeklinde olan bu
cümlelerin nasıl kurulduğunu 15. videoda
anlatıyorum. Önce sayı sıfatı olan 1
ardından niteleme sıfatım olan geniş
sözcüğü gelecek. Hepsinden önce ise evet
hayırlı soru cümleme yardımcı fiil artı
özne ile başlayacağım.
Is this a large sofa?
Evinizin dört odası var mı?
Evinizin dört odası var mı? Yani başka
bir deyişte eviniz dört odaya sahip mi?
Odaların eve ait olduğu belli. Bu yüzden
sahip olmak anlamına gelen have fiilini
kullanacağız. 16. videoda bunu
detaylarıyla anlatmıştım. Tekrar
izleyebilirsiniz.
Artık geniş zaman öğrendiğimize göre hem
Amerikan hem de İngiliz kullanımıyla bu
cümleyi kurabiliriz. Önce have got
şeklindeki ingiliz kullanımına bakalım.
Öznem olan sizin eviniz ifadesiyle bir
tane ev kastedildiği için cümleye has
ile başlamam gerekiyor. Has your house
got four rooms?
Amerikalılar ise geniş zaman yapısını
kullanıyor ve bu bir soru cümlesi olduğu
için have fiiline s takısı ekleyip has
şeklinde kullanmıyorlar.
Yalın hali olan have kelimesini tercih
ediyorlar. Does your house have four
rooms?
Evinizde kaç tane oda var?
Bu sefer evinizin demeyip evinizde
dediği için bir aitlik söz konusu değil
ve var anlamını vermek için there is
there are yapısının kullanılması
gerekiyor. 17. Dersin konusu olan there
is there are ifadelerini kullanmadan
önce kaç tane diyelim ve hemen ardından
neyin kaç tane olduğunu soralım.
How many'den sonra gelen nesne daima
çoğul halde gelmeliydi. Bu bir soru
cümlesi olduğu için there are yapısını
ters çevirelim ve peşinden de evinizde
yani sizin evinizin içinde diyelim.
How many rooms are there in your house?
Torbada hiç şeker yok.
Yine bu cümlede de yok anlamını vermek
için there is there are yapısını
kullanacağız. Sayılabilen ve sayılamayan
nesneleri öğrettiğim 18. videoda şeker
gibi küçük taneli şeylerin
sayılamayacağından bahsetmiştim.
sayılmayan nesnelere tekilmiş gibi
muamele ediyoruz ve bu yüzden cümleye
there isn't ile başlıyoruz. Peşinden de
hiç anlamına gelen any sözcüğünü şekerin
başına yazıyoruz. Geriye bir tek nerede
şeker olmadığını yazmak kaldı. There
isn't any sugar in the back.
Aa be torbaada mı demekmiş?
Onları yiyebilir misin?
İngilizcede beceri belirten ebilmek
anlamını ken sözcüğü ile veriyoruz. Bu
konunun detaylarını 19. videoda
bulabilirsiniz.
Soru cümlesi olduğu için can ile
başlayıp ardından öznemi yazıyorum. Can
ile kurduğumuz tüm cümlelerde fiili
yalın halde kullanacağız. Geriye bir tek
onları demek kaldı ki bunu da nesne
zamirlerini anlattığım 21. derste
öğretmiştim.
Can you eat them?
Mavi etek on değil.
Bu cümlenin öznesi mavi etek. Olumlu bir
cümle olduğu için özneyle başlıyorum.
Söyleyen ve dinleyen hangi mavi eteğin
kastedildiğini bildiği için başına the
ekleyeceğim. Olumsuzluk anlamı katmak
için ve etek bir tane olduğu için
yardımcı fiil olarak isn't kullanıyorum.
E geriye bir tek onun demek kaldı ama
devamından herhangi bir kelime gelmediği
için her kullanmayacağımızı 20. derste
öğrenmiştik.
İlgi zamiri olan HSE kelimesini
kullanmamız gerekiyor. The blue skirt
isn't hurse.
Git ve yatağında uyu.
Emir cümlelerini anlattığım 22. derste
bu tür bir olumlu emir cümlesinin
doğrudan fiille başladığını söylemiştim.
İki ayrı fiilimi yan yana yazarak
cümleye başlıyorum.
Yatağında kelimesiyle senin yatağının
içinde ifadesinin kastedildiğini
düşünerek in your bed ile de cümleyi
bitiriyorum. Go and sleep in your bed.
Oturma odasını boyuyoruz.
Boyuyoruz kelimesinden ben bu cümlenin
şimdiki zamanda olduğunu anlıyorum. 23.
videoda öğrendiğimiz bilgileri
kullanarak bu olumlu cümleye özne artı
yardımcı fiille başlamalıyız.
Peçinden fiil gelecek ancak fiilimizin
sonuna anlamını veren ink takısını
eklemeyi unutmuyoruz.
Son olarak da nesnemizi yazacağız ama
nesnemiz sitting room değil.
liv room.
Sabahları genellikle ne yaparsın?
Yaparsın ve genellikle kelimelerinden bu
cümlenin geniş zamanda olduğunu
anlayabiliriz.
W soru kelimelerinden birini de içerdiği
için cümleye onunla başlamalıyız.
öznemize uygun bir yardımcı fiil
seçiyoruz.
Genellikle anlamına gelen usul
kelimesini getirmenin tam sırası. Çünkü
bu zaman zarfı fiilden hemen önce
geliyor demiştik. Şimdi bir do sözcüğü
daha getireceğiz ama bu do yardımcı fiil
olan do'dan farklı.
Neresi farklı hocam? Aynı kelime. İşte
buradaki do yapmak anlamına gelen
fiilimiz.
Geriye bir tek sabahları demek kaldı ki
bunu da nasıl söyleyeceğimizi 24. derste
öğrendik. What do you usually do in the
mornings?
Ona inanmıyorum.
Bu cümle her ne kadar şimdiki zamanda
gibi görünse de aslında içerdiği durum
fiilinden ötürü İngilizcede geniş
zamanda kurulması gereken bir cümle.
Durum fiillerinin neler olduğunu
hatırlamıyorsanız 26. videoyu bir kere
daha izleyebilirsiniz.
Bir eylem değil de durum bildiren
fiillere durum fiilleri diyorduk ve
ortak özellikleri sonlarına ink takısı
almamalarıydı.
in alamadıkları için de şimdiki zamanda
kullanılamayıp şimdiki zamana en yakın
zaman olan geniş zamanda
kullanılabiliyorlardı.
O zaman hemen bir geniş zaman olumsuz
cümle yapısıyla cümlemizi kuralım. I
don't believe him.
Deniz kenarındaki bir evde yaşıyoruz.
Bu cümle de tıpkı bir önceki cümle gibi
şimdiki zamandaymış gibi görünse de
geniş zamanda kurulması gereken bir
cümle.
Neden hocam? Yaşamak durum fiili mi?
Aslında değil ama İngilizcede şimdiki
zamanı tam konuşma anında meydana gelen
şeyler için kullanıyoruz demiştik.
Burada ise genele özgü bir durum söz
konusu olduğundan geniş zaman tercih
edeceğiz. Sizinle de bu cümleyi şimdiki
zamanda kuracağım der ve kurarsanız
tenis kenarındaki bir evde geçici olarak
yaşadığı sonucu çıkar.
Ancak benim bu cümleyi dahil etme
sebebim daha çok 27. videoya gönderme
yapmaktı. Çünkü kenarında sözcüğünü
neyle karşılayacağımızı o videoda
öğretmiştim. Bu kullanmamız gerekiyor.
We live in a house by the sea.
10 yıl önce bu ev burada yoktu.
yoktu ifadesinden bunun be fiilinin was
hallerinden biriyle yapılması gereken
bir dili geçmiş zaman cümlesi olduğu
anlaşılıyor. 28. videoda bu konuyu
ayrıntılarıyla bulabilirsiniz.
Tek bir evden bahsedildiği için özneden
sonra wasn't kullanmak uygun olacak.
Peşinden de önce yer zarfımızı ardından
zarfımızı getireceğiz.
This house wasn't here 10 years ago.
Dün onu görmedik.
Bu cümle bir dili geçmiş zaman cümlesi.
Ancak bir önceki cümleden farklı olarak
içinde görmek fiili geçiyor. Bu yüzden
bu cümleyi 29. derste anlatılan kurallar
çerçevesinde yapmamız gerekiyor.
Dili geçmiş zamanda olumsuz cümle kurma
kurallarını hatırlayalım. Öyleyse özne
ile başlarız. Peşinden did yardımcı
fiilini getiririz. Ardından fiilimizi
yalan halde yazarız. Daha sonra da
nesnemizi ve zaman zarfımızı getiririz.
We didn't see him yesterday.
Evet, gördüğünüz gibi zihnimizi farklı
farklı çalıştırarak şu ana kadar
öğrendiğimiz konuların pekişmesini
sağladık. Genel revizyon üniteleri bu
açıdan çok faydalı. Elbette 20 cümleye
tüm konular sığamayacağı için son
öğrenilen 5 veya 10 konuyu kapsayacak
şekilde düzenlendiler.
Bu tür alıştırmalar hoşunuza gittiyse
devamını Çeviri ile Öğren kitabında
bulabilirsiniz. Tanıtım ve satış
sayfasına gitmek için sağ üst köşedeki i
harfine tıklayabilirsiniz.
Ayrıca bu kanala yükleyeceğim yeni
videolardan haberdar olmak için sol
köşeye tıklayarak kanalıma abone
olabilirsiniz. İzlediğiniz için teşekkür
ederim. Bir sonraki videoda görüşmek
üzere. Hoşça kalın.
[Müzik]